jusqu'au bout comme ils l'ont si souvent
fait depuis les 26 dernières années j'ai
attendu et Patrick Roy se sont assis à
la même table au terme d'une autre
saison de Aki junior cette fois pour
annoncer la fin de leur aventure avec
les remparts et aujourd'hui je quitte
mes fonctions avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli aujourd'hui après 26 ans
je pense que c'est le temps de laisser
la place à des plus jeunes la décision
ne surprend personne les rumeurs
allaient bon trains et le triomphe en
final de la coupe mémoriale la semaine
dernière n'a fait que convaincre les
deux associés et amis qu'il était temps
pour eux de tourner la page
intérieurement c'est ça ça me fait de la
peine un peu utilisé je quitte des gens
que j'aime puis c'est ma gang puis mais
c'est tellement une belle fin que c'est
je peux pas demander mieux ça a été le
summum de ce que je pouvais vivre au
niveau du hockey
fait que je remercie Patrick je remercie
l'organisation mais il y a rien qui
aurait pu faire changer d'idée après
avoir acheté les harpent de beaux ports
en 1996 Jacques Tanguy et Patrick Roy
ont fait revivre les remparts et ils en
ont fait l'une des meilleures
organisations de tout le Haki junior
canadien leur départ sera difficile à
combler tant pour l'équipe
que pour les partisans je peux pas
remplacer Patrick il y aura un nouveau
général un nouveau président un nouvel
entraîneur mais Patrick Roy auront été
les deux plus grands bâtisseurs de
l'histoire des Remparts de Québec point
la ligne si vraiment une grosse perte
c'est incroyable je crois qu'il soit le
remplacer mais en charge
ces derniers auront peut-être la chance
de revoir Patrick Roy derrière un banc
de la Ligue nationale
certains estiment qu'il pourrait devenir
le prochain entraîneur des Sénateurs
d'Ottawa roi ne s'en cache pas il rêve
d'un retour dans la LNH et quelqu'un il
m'avait déjà à moi un moment donné
c'est pas ta passion c'est ta vie puis
c'est un peu vrai l'orchester ma vie
l'appel est lancée voyons aussi une
équipe lui donnera sa chance ici
Jean-Philippe Martin Radio-Canada Québec